[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the daily
mails consultant editor andrew pearce
and the daily mirrors associate editor
kevin mcguire super to see both of you
anyway front pages as ever let us kick
off with the metro reporting that
legally binding covert restrictions
could end in as little as two weeks from
now with boris johnson expected to
confirm the changes on february the 21st
same story for the guardian their
headline covert rules to be abolished in
england in a fortnight
meanwhile at least 50 people are
expected to be contacted in the coming
days by metropolitan police officers
investigating parties in downey street
during lockdown that's according to the
telegraph front of the eye reports on
the same story writing that boris
johnson and his wife will be questioned
by the met
seven days to respond to formal
questionnaires as the times as their
headline with the same story the front
of the sun focusing on west ham
footballer kurt zuma's cats being
rescued by the rspca after footage of
him revealed he abused them financial
times has details of plans by america's
fiscal regulator to improve transparency
around hedge funds
and the mirror has a story concerning
the personal life of colleen and wayne
rooney and of course that photo in down
the street which was broken today by
pippa clearer
so a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us listen to our guests so let's
bring them in andrew pearce and kevin
mcguire welcome to you so kevin let you
kick off then leading a number of the
newspapers this idea that if you test
positive you won't need to isolate and
it's coming in quite soon
no that's right god you're not leading
on it we were expecting the to change
march 24th but it now looks like
february 24th brought
forward in england by a month uh the
prime minister unexpectedly announced it
and prime minister's questions i suspect
he wanted to change the
uh news agenda away from parties to some
extent he's he's done that because we
can see there it's at the front of the
the guardian it also
shows up his support amongst uh the
rather large lockdown skeptic uh wing of
his own party uh interestingly um
sage the uh the advisers say they knew
nothing about this uh so has he got new
scientific advice or was it all about uh
politics it may be sensible it may it
may not um but it's interesting when you
look at the
figures that are still there i was just
looking at them today 276 deaths
announced okay that's down uh cases
sixty eight thousand uh that's down as
well hospital hospital admissions down
but uh ten thousands people still
admitted in the last full week 430
people still on ventilators it's
certainly a gamble but i think the
the mood of much of the nation now i
think is out there they're fed up and
they want to see the the end of
restrictions although that legal
requirement to
self-isolate for five days should you
test positive i think it's particularly
onerous compared to the restrictions we
had in the past yes and that's certainly
the argument that some people make you
know five days possibly a sixth you know
it's not it's not that bad and how do
you avoid getting it now um to be fair
downey street as the guardian is quoting
here will set out guidance but confirm
people would be advised to avoid going
to work if they test positive for covid
in the same way that if you have flu you
would not be expected to go and infect
your colleagues but you know
at some point when the when the laws
changed you know children of a positive
household were being forced to go in so
if a child is positive would they be
expected to go to school what happens to
vulnerable teachers you know there's so
many questions about this andrew for
people
i think people just have to use their
common sense anna uh because why should
governments prescribe how we behave if
we get a heavy cold or the flu
of course most people should stay at
home but a lot of people don't and i
think it's really antisocial that they
don't if you've got the flu by the way
you ain't gonna go to work because if
you've got real flu it flattens you
but um i think this is a really sensible
move i don't i think the fact that sage
didn't know about it means it is a
political decision it would have been
agreed with the cabinet um
what makes it sensible
because why because because the
everything is going down number of
hospital infections are down no multiple
admissions are down uh the number of
deaths are down we've not had it we it
was omicron has never been anything like
the delta variant it's time to get the
country moving again it's time to let
the country start living with covert
we've got to learn to live with kovid
that's been the advice for a long time
now and it's about time we did it's
central and i'm glad he's getting on
with it we are we are living with covid
that's why most of the restrictions have
gone there's some mass there are some
masks wearing for instance on london
transport you'll be regressing drain i
was recently between london and uh and
newcastle some shops will do it but most
of the big restrictions have gone the
reason you have isolation if you have it
is you don't spread it that's the idea
now if you lift that isolation and
people
will probably stop testing and they're
go they're going out to work or they're
just going to shopping and going to
football whatever
then then it could take off again that
is that is the danger i know this labor
is criticized the timing saying he you
went uh
johnson to the house of commons and said
it didn't really have any anything else
to say labor hasn't criticized the
lifting and there's a bit of a bind here
for labor what do they
do
when these restrictions are lifted do
they call for them to stay in place i'm
not sure they will they'll be trying to
weigh
weigh it up but there's a psychology to
this andrew there's a psychology to this
let me just finish if you don't mind
we've all been told to be petrified of
this thing for ages and there are
certain cohorts in society who will
continue to be petrified you know some
people are vulnerable have been in tears
about this and to give people no notice
to adjust to the idea that actually the
person stood next to them in a shop you
know may well be positive and it doesn't
matter they're allowed out and about all
that sort of stuff or how you keep your
parents safe when you know all the way
through people need time to adjust to
that do you think well well they're
getting two weeks to adjust yeah that's
plenty of time but we've not had
guidance how many more anna how many
more months do you want to lock this
country down we've been locked down for
two years
yeah well of course people are locking
down because they're not shut down they
have to stay at home for five days if
they get if they go down even if they've
got if they're not ill they don't feel
unwell they didn't even know they've got
omicron until they've got a positive
test it's causing chaos in the nhs it's
still causing chaos in business economy
is on its knees let's get back to normal
okay god dear me
i think some people would like you
locked up andrew but the uh you're at
mcguire
playing opportunism all over this all
over again
they were against the restriction they
were against johnson relaxing the
restrictions before christmas and
johnson was proved right yeah yeah well
the scottish the scottish government's
asked for urgent clarification clearly
no notice given there either which takes
us to our next door saying they've got
yes the mandating of rules their
suggestion is they might be extended by
six months as well so we'll watch and
wait to see what they do but in the
meantime well she does her own thing
anyway sturgeon this all happened house
of commons
first minister this all happened in the
house of commons uh during premises
questions when you could see the torah
back benches all checking their phones
after pippa cru in the mirror revealed
yet another
photograph of an event we already know
about we've already seen a bit of that
tinsel in the photo um but what's the
difference with this one is it the booze
and the crisps kevin
it's exactly that because
the metropolitan police decided not to
investigate this quiz on the 15th of
december in 2020
didn't pass a threshold now they're
looking at it doesn't say they will
investigate it but it looks more of a
party when you see that open bottle of
fears when you see those crisps the last
pitcher had the prime minister he was
flanked by somebody wearing a tinsel
that person somebody in a
santa hat but it certainly sounded like
a
a party to me when yes some people
joined from home but others were in
teams in downing street teams like hans
first place
uh and um next slide please it was in
that uh
they kind of have a laugh at chris witty
uh in a nice way
mood um but the
the mets i think uh clearly didn't have
the photograph because they've got 300
photographs they're looking at but if
they're now
reviewing their decision not to
investigate what would be the 13th party
a baker's given doesn't
you know with an extra one added to the
the dirt he doesn't already under
scrutiny you can see boris johnson just
isn't out of it and if there are 300
other photographs that the police have
how many do others have and i think it's
very hard for him to escape this he's
got himself in a real mess by one state
saying there were no parties then two
all the rules were followed then three
he was incredibly surprised to discover
there'd been
parties and then four just sort of
putting his hands up and saying
look wait for an investigation when he
was shown to be at parties and then
fifth starting to apologize for some of
the parties in downing street
you could carry on all night with that
list
but the whole point is
yeah the whole the met police revealed
some of some of their investigation the
pa copy on this reads detectives
investigating lockdown parties in
downing street are to send out
questionnaires to people believed to
have taken part goodness me we're
talking about the potential demise of a
british prime minister in his government
andrew and the way to investigate this
is via a questionnaire
well just but just to go back to the
party why i think that picture of the
party's significant we were in tier two
restrictions and those tier two
restrictions did say you could not have
a christmas party or even a christmas
lunch so that's why potentially the
police may now investigate it after all
now the what the police will do they're
gonna send email questions to the 50
staff and i think as a result of those
responses which are
you've got to answer them honestly and
if you don't you're in trouble um i
think they will then question people
that's the point i think they're not i
think i think they i think it's like a
sifting process because down history we
know is a very big place there's about
400 people work there at times uh so um
and and i suspect the prime minister
will be will get the email too and if
his response isn't uh doesn't pass that
the police test i imagine they'll
interview him in the same way they
interviewed tony blair what would be
interesting during the cash for honors
investigation is would they interview
the prime minister
under caution well the diff
the difference would be that tony blair
was interviewed as a witness that's
right
boris johnson would i suspect be
interviewed as a suspect and that's why
it could be under caution but those
fines you can get on the fixed penalty
notice that they're between 200 pounds
and 10 000 pounds they're now fearing in
downing street those who are regular
party animals and went to a lot could
get multiple fines rather than just uh
just
uh
one
by
by product this could be a they could
raise a lot of money for rather straight
and public finances but the
i are reporting that uh boris johnson
fears more letters will go in and there
could be a coup against him if he gets a
fixed penalty notice which would be an
extraordinary position if he has found
or who broken the law and is actually
fined when he is in power
yeah
just quickly don't get a criminal but
just say you don't get a criminal record
if you get a fixed penalty notice but um
some people who've organized parties
outside of downing street have been
fined up to 10 000 pounds now i don't
think the prime minister's organized any
of these parties but as a guest
potentially he could get a fix and a
penalty notice and then would he where
do you have to go yes it all depends on
the date of the party compared to the
law at the time doesn't it but we will
see how that all comes out uh before the
end of the week officers will be sending
out those questionnaires uh plenty more
still to come the foreign secretary
touches down in moscow but what role
might she play in de-escalating the
ukraine conflict back with that in just
a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire welcome back to both
of you so uh to liz truss in moscow we
asked the question before the break what
role will she play and you see this
photo and you just want to shout dr
zhivago don't you to be fair andrew
look do you know what this is mrs
thatcher all over again when mrs
thatcher went to moscow in 1987 when she
thought gorbachev she wore all these
amazing acquisition outfits including
cossack cats so we've seen liz cross on
a tank like mrs thatcher when she was
racing against the german champion goal
here she is again dressing like mrs
thatcher she ain't mrs thatcher however
as the foreign secretary she's over
there to see lavrov her foreign camp her
counterpart waste of time talking to him
he's got absolutely no clout no
influence whatsoever the gangster putin
makes all the decisions but it's a great
photo opportunity for her and she never
misses a chance but that's exactly the
point this is not about her it's about
the fact that large parts of the black
sea and the sea of assaf have been
closed today by russia that the
exercises in belarus are due to start
tomorrow that actually this is looking
extremely serious and and and you know
there's a nice bit of posing in front of
you know that part of moscow i can't see
the whole photo we've got we've got her
tweet have we um to see anyway kevin
i know she's the instagram secretary she
just likes to go and pose and dress up
everywhere i remember the old kids
cartoon series mr ben and go in one door
dressed as a soldier and call out the
next one as a firefighter that is her
i wish he's hired quite a few people to
get our image but uh andrew says lafros
has got no uh influence and client you i
think he could probably apply the same
to um liz trust actually as foreign
secretary
she's really she wants the top job but
she goes around posing and look
going going in front of a landmark to
show where you are would be quite normal
but she just seems to put so much focus
on this she's not going to be heard
you're not gonna be heard at all i think
we saw macron uh sitting at the other
end of that long table from
putin he struggled to be heard i think
johnson would be struggling he had to
shout you mean
yeah well he did yeah
um you want to talk about the cats
you've got 20 seconds we'll do it again
later but 20 seconds on the cats and uh
kurt zuma west ham
andrew too little too late too little
too late that man should not have been
allowed to play on that football match
last night an absolute pr disaster for
west ham i'm glad he's um big that he's
lost some sponsors 250 000 pounds two
weeks money nothing to that footballer
he's disgusting he's a bully it's
horrible what he did to those cats